matteo salvini ha vuelto a lampedusa la
isla se ha convertido en el escenario de
campaña electoral de este político de
extrema derecha que busca convertirse en
el primer ministro de italia en las
elecciones del próximo 25 de septiembre
en el centro de estrés y los italianos
eligen al partido de la liga la
centroderecha eligen volver al control y
la protección de las fronteras de acoger
plenamente a los que huyen de la guerra
que es una minoría de los que están en
italia y volver a la protección de las
fronteras y al director de área de
detalle quien tiene derecho a venir a
italia bien en avión no viene en una
barca arriesgando su vida quien no tiene
derecho no llega
las cifras de la organización
internacional para las migraciones
hablan de una realidad distinta el
mediterráneo se ha tragado más de 20 mil
vidas desde 2014 y después de la
interrupción de la pandemia cada vez son
más los que intentan cruzar el mar
aprovechando ahora los climas más
clementes del verano
sólo en el último mes los barcos de ongs
rescataron a unas mil personas muchos
desembarcar en lampedusa esta isla de 20
kilómetros cuadrados en el corazón del
mediterráneo cuyo centro de acogida
alberga ahora mismo a más de 1500
personas cuatro veces más de lo que le
permiten sus instalaciones
quién es presencia en este drama
humanitario de primera mano tachan la
visita de salvini de espectáculo en una
actividad de propaganda es una actividad
de propaganda y creo que es vergonzoso
horrible es una propaganda que usa el
color de piel de la gente gente que
sufre de verdad gente que muere en el
mar pero de las personas
la principal huella de salvini como
ministro de exteriores- en 2019 fue
cerrar los puertos italianos a estos
barcos de rescate y una política
parecida se divisa en el horizonte si
gana las elecciones
una victoria que las encuestas ven
posibles